we have a major two-part development in
Trump Russia that I want to tell you
about and some of you have noticed I
know because you've written to me that
we've been easing off of the Trump
Russia stories lately lots of little
things have happened in the last couple
of weeks in Trump Russia and I've been
trying to cover really just the big
picture of it increasingly talking about
the 2018 midterms in relation to Trump
Russia not so much following the
day-to-day other than that really big
recent story about Michael Cohen
although that story is becoming much
bigger and sort of independent than
Trump Russia anyway there are now some
really big developments relating to that
Russian lawyer Natalya vessel Mnet's
kaya who you might recall met with
Donald Trump jr. and Paul Manafort and
many others in Trump Tower
so there's news about her and there's
also news about the wacky and outrageous
way that Donald Trump reacted to the
vessel that's kaya news so let's first
start with the facts Natalia vessel
that's kaya secured a meeting in Trump
Tower with Donald Trump jr. and other
campaign officials on the basis that she
was going to be bringing to them
possible dirt on Hillary Clinton it was
intimated to Natalia vessel Nets kaya
that if indeed she was able to deliver
the dirt and help Donald Trump win then
the incoming Trump administration the
event potential Trump administration
would be willing to look at easing
Russian sanctions related to the
Magnitsky Act this is an offer for a
quid pro quo really really bad the
defense to this from the Trump team
while there have been numerous defenses
number one no one really thought she was
bringing dirt on Hillary so there was no
quid pro quo number two no real quid pro
quo was offered we just said listen if
we're president if Trump is president we
would look at sanctions number three
Trump had no idea about it so in the end
it doesn't matter it's hard to believe
and number four that this is just some
random Russian lawyer who is in no way
connected to the Russian government
she's not a spy she's not an informant
she's not authorized to do any work on
behalf of the Kremlin that fourth claim
has now crumbled because of documents
that have been released and reported on
by the New York Times and because of
what Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya herself
said in an interview on NBC News so for
the documents emails show that she
actually worked directly with Russia's
head legal office against a US Justice
Department fraud case which was being
litigated against a Russian firm not
just a random private lawyer she also
has recanted her own claims that she has
nothing to do with the Russian
government during an NBC News interview
she said yeah actually I was a source of
information for a top Kremlin official
whose name is Yuri chica the prosecutor
general this is another way to say that
she was a Russian informant a term often
used interchangeably for Russian spies
spy doesn't mean operating in literal
shadows late at night it means in many
cases informing government officials of
what's going on here or there Donald
Trump jr. and Paul Manafort and whoever
else was in the room at Trump Tower met
with a Russian government informant on
the pretense that she might be bringing
dirt on Trump's opponent and with an
intimated quid pro quo of helping to
ease sanctions if she delivered the dirt
so that already is huge now there's a
reasonable question that skeptics would
ask here or really anyone who's thinking
critically if this was a Russian agent a
Russian informant whatever why did she
do all that stuff then and now admits to
it right like why is she now all of a
sudden admitting to this stuff and this
is what I've been saying for years this
is the model create instability if
eventually if we find out what really
went on here we will likely find out
that a trump presidency was not actually
their end it was their means
Trump was the Patsy the sort of
convenient clown the real goal is to
expose American democracy as being in
chaos to create outrage to pile up
scandals to make it even more difficult
for Trump to operate once you understand
that and you understand that this has
been the long-standing Russian playbook
right for dealing with the United States
I've talked about the 1997 book
foundations of geopolitics by Alexander
Dugan
then it becomes clear why the same
person Natalia vessel Nets kaya would
both try to get involved with the Trump
campaign covertly and then later admit
to who she is so that's the news as far
as the lawyer herself is concerned but
just the stunning or maybe even more is
how Donald Trump reacted to this news
which is what I want to talk about next
okay today's program is made possible in
part by
Fort or the social forecasting game
where players come together and compete
with each other to predict future events
you can play the game on the Android or
iOS app or in your web browser you can
wager on everything from politics to
sports in the games in game fake
currency I'm on Foote or you can find my
account and follow me by clicking the
link in the description if you're
watching this on YouTube this week on
food tour I pose the question will
Democrats flip the US Senate in 2018
what do you think click the link in the
description make your wagers and you can
browse the politics category on future
to find other predictions sign up at
Foote or comms start making your
forecasts on political topics or
anything else free it's on Android iOS
and your web browser and it's spelled
fut you you are calm